it's just Heaven oh the blessed life you
are living yes ma'am
according to an eyewitness right around
9 25 this morning Mr Jordan's car hit a
parked car just beyond us and then
careened into the building behind us
firefighters arrived at the scene
quickly and they tried to resuscitate
him for a short time before his body was
covered and he was pronounced dead
that's his personal assistant and friend
for the last eight years he's much like
his Persona
um more loving more caring and more
Charming now that is Leslie's assistant
he was visibly upset and in shock
according to an eyewitness Mr Jordan has
a new condo close to here they see him
often and another eyewitness told us
that he suffered some kind of medical
emergency and his car narrowly missed
someone on the sidewalk I learned a
valuable lesson appreciate every day of
your life Jordan wanted me for his role
of Beverly Leslie on Will and Grace and
is a recurring character on the fox
sitcom call me cat it's unclear how the
show will handle his death he visited
the ET set many times co-hosting with us
last fall oh man thank you for stopping
by it is always so good to see you
coming to see you the 67 year old was
spotted alongside that same BMW last
month and seemed to be in good health he
became a social media star during the
pandemic and this was Leslie's last post
just one day ago performing a new
original song with songwriter Danny
Myrick your struggle with drugs and
alcohol what led to that decision you
know about sobriety my unfortunate
incarceration
in May of 2021 Leslie came to E.T to
talk about confessions made in his book
how y'all doing I used to live in Van
Nuys but I like to drink in Hollywood
because that's where most of the fun
bars were every time I'd get pulled over
by this one car and that woman should go
baby baby
when are you gonna put the plug in The
Jug and so
I went immediately
into rehab who wants to live in a world
without Leslie Jordan
from Andy Cohen to Kevin McHale the
Stars paid tribute Leslie's Will and
Grace co-star Sean Hayes posted my heart
is broken there will never be anyone
like him you will be missed my dear
friend
[Music]